tout au long de ses 75 années est ce que
la parole de la france a évolué est ce
qu elle a été plus ou moins entendu en
fonction des périodes et l'a peut-être
fait ea se pervertir
il faut rappeler quelque chose on ne
sait pas où est passé le manuscrit du
petit prince de saint-exupéry
on a retrouvé deux feuillet il ya
quelques années il y en a un qui est
porteur grandement porteur de sens dans
la version définitive du type pince sa
texture rappelle que deux milliards
d'habitants c'est le nombre de terriens
sur sa planète dans les années 40
pourrait tenir sur une île dont il se
contente de donner la taille
et puis dans le brouillon il il
détaillait il y avait tout le monde
parmi ces deux milliards d'habitants
les jeunes les vieux les jaunes les
rouges les blancs les noirs et puis
lille s'est elle engagée landes
alors j'ai adapté la parabole de
saint-exupéry a aujourd'hui nous serons
dans quelques années 8 milliards
d'habitants 8 milliards d'habitants
debout collé serré pourrait tenir sur
une fois et demie l'île de corse que
voulait dire saint-exupéry et c'est
peut-être la voix humaniste que la
france peut porter en tout cas quelle
qu'elle a commencé à porter avec de
gaulle dans sa deuxième manière le monde
la planète n'est pas démographiquement
surpeuplée pas géographiquement
surpeuplé nous sommes socialement
économiquement économiquement surpeuplé
pour deux raisons d'abord le refus du
partage
je rappelle le cas dit il personne qui
abolissent 50 % des richesses de
l'humanité et puis surtout ou à côté de
tout ça le grand gaspillage
le grand gaspillage puisqu'un tiers de
ce que nous produisons de par le monde
passe à la poubelle là il ya une voie
mais on parlait de l'unilatéralisme ou
de bilatéralisme certains pays remettent
en question tous les problèmes cruciaux
actuellement le problème climatique
refuse le partage et refusent la théorie
du gaspillage qui est une certitude
il ya là une voie et si je dis qu'elle a
failli se pervertir c'est que le monde a
été pris
sous le joug de la folie d'un
ultralibéralisme que de gaulle redoutait
beaucoup de gauche n'était pas anti
libérale il se méfiait des ultralibéraux
qui à ses yeux était aussi dangereux que
les staliniens
alors voilà est ce que la france geri de
certaines tentations peut-être par par
la pandémie par la coc div 19 est-ce
qu'elle va atterrir et poussé le monde à
avoir une vision un peu moins ultra
libérale un peu plus sage un peu plus
humaniste en s'appuyant sur tous les
pays qu'ils évitent cette politique de
blocs cet impérialisme des états unis de
la chine ou de quelques autres que nous
évoquions toner